[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es eine mond
käsekuchen oder käse mohnkuchen ich kann
mich beim namen ohne diesem monat schon
okay einen käse mondkuchen nein haben
sich enorm und stimmiger ihr könnt ihr
wisst ihr was ihr könnt entscheiden und
wir ändern dementsprechend dann den
titel also heute geht es jedenfalls ein
kuchen der beinhaltet etwas mohn in
einen käsekuchen den sieht so hübsch aus
es gibt halt auch wenig klassische mond
asse kuchen dann ist dann so eine dicke
mond steht und eine kirche geschichte
und ich habe mir wie kann ich das
hübscher gestalten und das zeige ich
euch heute wir machen jetzt nämlich
zuallererst einen mürbeteig und danach
kommt schon die mohn masse wir verkneten
jetzt in einer großen schüssel mehl
zucker eine prise salz butter und ein ei
und das macht ihr einfach mit den händen
bei mir ist es so dass die butterweich
ist deswegen geht das alles auch ein
bisschen einfacher
und sobald ihr einen festen teig
erhaltet einfach hier in
frischhaltefolie wickeln ein bisschen
flach drücken und dann für eine halbe
stunde in den kühlschrank geben in der
zeit lösen sich die zuckerkristalle auf
das ganze wird ein bisschen fester und
dann können wir weitermachen
[Musik]
so will der mütter im kühlschrank vor
sich hin kühlt machen wir schon mal die
mond füllung und dafür habe ich hier
bleiben einfach 30 sekunden im mix am
liebsten damit einfach nur ein bisschen
feiner wird und den müssen wir jetzt
aufkochen und quellen lassen
dafür gebe ich den mond einmal in meinem
kopf der hat jetzt gerade noch aus dazu
gebe ich etwas zucker weil ich finde
süße gehört da auch noch mit rein und
ein bisschen milch und dann kochen wir
das auf und lassen das köchelt für
ungefähr zwei minuten aber nicht länger
[Musik]
sonst hätte ich den herd nach zwei
minuten ausgeschaltet jetzt gebt ihr
butter dazu das macht das ganze dann
später ein bisschen geschmeidiger und
die darf dann in der rest hitze
schmelzen so und anschließend geht es
einfach nur den deckel drauf und dann
arbeitet der mond quasi vor sich hin
quält auf und dann brauchen wir das
später erst wieder
wir machen jetzt gleich weiter mit
unserem mürbeteig den mürbeteig damit
den händen ganz kurz geschmeidig kneten
und dann kleinen wir einen 26 cm
tortenring mit dem teig aus dem harz am
besten so zwei drittel kommen auf den
boden und ein drittel auf den rand an
den rand so und da werde ich jetzt den
boden mit einer gabel einstechen einfach
damit er nicht hochgeht gleich nach dem
backen und dann kühle ich dir nochmal
bis zur weiterverarbeitung
[Musik]
so und jetzt hören wir eine käsekuchen
masse zusammen auf quark basis da habe
ich hier lag auf marker stufe ihr
könntet auch einen neben der mehr fett
hat aber meiner meinung nach das nicht
nötig weil wir sowieso noch fed dazu
packen also öl und das führe ich jetzt
ganz einfach miteinander ohne maschine
einfach nur mit dem schneebesen man
könnte ja das geht auf jeden fall ja ich
glaube auch so zucker und vanille
extrakt passt auch sehr gut so hier
könnt ihr sonnenblumen oder rapsöl
benutzen hauptsache irgendwas neutrale
das ist ja es ist ein land voller aber
ist nichts daneben gegangen
jawoll so und die milch dazu
für die bindung kommen da noch einer
hinzu und stärke und die stärke sieht
ihr bitte und dann ist die kirche kuchen
machst du fertig falls ihr euch wundern
busch ihnen die ganz genaue
mengenangaben unten in der video
beschreibung einfach screen schotten und
ab zu kaufland so und ich mache jetzt
hier folgendes ich gebe jetzt von meiner
mond füllung die darf ruhig noch lauwarm
sein dass es nicht ganz so schlimm da
gibt es fast alles auf den boden meines
blogs und hebe aber zwei esslöffel auf
und da kommt dann gleich er die hübsche
decoder freue ich mich schon die ganze
zeit drauf
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es lustig jetzt sind einfach
ein messer sowie jan oft aus eine kuh
und jetzt machen wir es war ein ganz
unregelmäßig ja das ist wie eine
therapie
jetzt verstehe ich
[Musik]
das ist wie eine leinwand auf der ihr
zeichnet ich finde es so hübsch
also ich finde es so ästhetisch das wäre
doch auch mal ein geburtstagsgeschenk
jetzt mal ehrlich oder würdest du dich
freuen
auf jeden fall also ich pack das ganze
jetzt also direkt in den vorgeheizten
backofen geben bei 190 grad ober und
unterhitze für 50 minuten maximum 55 was
ich aber nicht glaube mir braucht er
immer 50 minuten und dann sind es nach
dem backen wieder tun
[Musik]
nach dem backen ist es wichtig dass ihr
euren kuchen komplett auskühlen lassen
und wirklich noch mal für zwei drei
stunden gerne auch über nacht in den
kühlschrank gibt das liegt einfach daran
dass die masse dann richtig schön fest
jetzt hab ich mir mein backform löser
und weise ganz vorsichtig erst mal die
torte vom tortenring und dann nehme ich
mir mein torten retter und geht das auf
eine schöne platte
[Musik]
also wenn die käsekuchen mögt dann müsst
ihr den unbedingt man ausprobiert haben
gerade in verbindung mit dämonen noch
mal sehr abwechslungsreich und auch die
masse ist sehr sehr cremig und dann
kommt dieser mo noch dazu
super-kombination unbedingt nachmachen
und falls ihr das danach gemacht habt
gerne auf instagram posten dann könnt
ihr mich töten dann schaue ich mir das
an
die poster euch und ansonsten schreibt
mir gerne ein kommentar wie euch das
rezept gefallen hat und ich hab dann sag
ich mal
wir sehen uns beim nächsten mal auf
einem kanal cherokee
[Musik]